do you tell patients to subscribe to
your channel imagine I walk into a room
hi I'm dr. Bartowski you were just
involved in a code blue please subscribe
please sub but some folks dr. Mike here
I'm back at it with another responding
to comments video I will say it's been a
while since I've done one of these but
you are slacking I want more questions
in the comment section get to it start
writing even if it's in the middle of
this video don't stop until you get your
question answered because I want to
answer all of them let's get started in
reality the only times my channel comes
up with my patients is if they already
know me or in the instance that we've
run out of time and a patient wants to
know about a specific subject and I know
I have a video on that subject I'll then
recommend that they check out one of my
videos but I don't push it on anybody
that's not for office time that's
strictly for us me you you and me you
know YouTube karen cobster dumb question
there is no such thing as a dumb
question in a heated situation where one
has to perform CPR
how does a person ensure that no ribs
get broken particularly the ones nearest
to the lungs well almost all the ribs
are near the lungs it's not something
you should think about that's the bottom
line what you should think about is
making sure that help is called that
you've nominated someone to call help or
call to help yourself
and right away if the person's not
breathing no pulse to start pounding on
that chest doing it out of 100 beats per
minute
singing stayin alive if you will and
pushing at least 2 inches deep so you
gotta push pretty firmly in order to
make that happen if you crack a rib no
worries you're extending the person's
life in order to get them help they're
already gone by doing the chest
compressions you're actually increasing
their chances for recovery that's the
best thing you can do when someone's
heart stops who tends to bear when you
work a long shift Robyn cherry Sigler
the great thing is is that one of my
close friends is my neighbor so he gets
to hang out with bear then my nephews
oftentimes take turns coming to see bear
sometimes I have someone clean my
apartment while I'm not home so there's
always someone taking care of bear or
hanging out with bear when he's alone
for a long period of time and I don't
work the 14-hour shift that you guys saw
in my vlog the other day
all the time that's like a once a week
thing where I have a really long shift
that I wanted to take you with me on but
in reality most of my shifts are shorter
than that and bears not alone for more
than you know six eight hours which he's
totally fine doing and he sleeps in the
bathroom even if I'm home at that time
anyway
bear do you hear his little feets hey
hey hey peppers you want to say hi to
the camera they want they want you to
say hi god you're such an aggressive
kisser bear ask for consent Conor Perry
can hats give you headaches great great
question
there's actually a type of headache
that's lesser known is called a
compression headache from wearing
helmets headband hats all of those
things that can put unnecessary pressure
on your scalp can actually cause you a
headache not to worry though generally
when you take those things off in a few
hours maybe if you need to take
something over-the-counter medication
it'll go away
but the reason this happens is because
there's always movement between the
sutures of your scalp and there's always
a little bit of movement
there's blood flow that needs to happen
there's a little bit of expansion there
and when you don't let that happen you
could actually get a headache known as a
compression headache so Connor great
question is it true that stress can lead
to the growing of white hairs or small
area I got to tell you I got them white
hair what's happening is actually you
have a decrease in melanin producing
cells called melanocytes in the hair
follicle if your hair is white that
means you completely have lost all your
melanin
but if you have some you get gray hair
so it's almost like partial pigmentation
if you will now the question you asked
is if stress affects it we know genetics
is the most important thing but stress
seems to play a role in this I've looked
into this myself we don't have a
cause-and-effect relationship let me
tell you that outright but when we look
into it we do see some sort of pattern
and correlation emerge between those who
don't sleep enough who have very
competitive jobs high stress levels at
work family members they generally great
earlier our reasoning for this which is
unproven but what we think happens
is that there's an inflammatory response
from free radicals that occurs from
stress and that actually interferes with
the melanin process like the way that
the color is brought to the follicle and
when that happens you're more likely to
grade earlier while science hasn't given
us a definitive answer I'm gonna give it
a preliminary truth that stress does
cause your hair to turn gray
sooner is cracking my knuckles a bad
idea
will I get arthritis well Henry I can't
promise if you're gonna get our thright
us or not but what I can tell you is
that medical research has looked into
the science of cracking knuckles and
that sound that you hear is actually
just nitrogen bubbles popping in your
synovial fluid synovial fluid is the
stuff that lubricates your joints and
when you hear that cracking you think
that's a bad thing
that's your bones breaking or anything
like that that's not really the case
it's these completely harmless nitrogen
bubbles and there's been really decent
evidence that shows it does not lead to
arthritis and unless it's causing you
some kind of pain or discomfort it's
usually and generally pretty harmless if
it makes you feel better psychologically
speaking crack away and as long as
you're not bothering anybody that's fine
now if you're getting pain when you're
cracking maybe you already have
arthritis maybe you have a tendon injury
definitely don't crack in those
scenarios if you find yourself needing
to crack otherwise you do have pain that
could also be a sign that something's
going on and you should talk to your
doctor but in general know that when you
crack your knuckles once see like now I
can't crack them again the reason why is
because you need to give time for those
nitrogen bubbles to reform in the
synovial fluid it's kind of a fun fact
for you
Catharine alert how many patients do you
have just wondering that's a good
question I see you around 3040 patients
a week in my outpatient office as a
family medicine doctor doing primary
care stuff and urgent care and then I
have probably a panel of like 500 600
patients that I built up from residency
who I'm their primary care doctor that
when they schedule an appointment for a
follow-up whatever it is they schedule
it with me this panel of patients that I
built up I'm a very close relationship
with
not all of them come in all the time and
sometimes they can get care from one of
my colleagues but they're important to
me because we've established a rapport I
know their history that's the beauty of
having a family medicine doctor so that
we don't give you unnecessary care and
we can guide you to the best specialist
the best imaging place is the best
physical therapists all of that
navigating the health system can be a
really troublesome fee and if you have a
good guide in a family medicine doctor
it's gonna save you a lot of time money
trouble and you're gonna get better
outcomes Marcos Morales aren't canker
sores and cold sores the same thing they
may look similar but they're actually
not the same thing at all
because of their cause cold sores are
caused by a virus and canker sores are
sometimes can be caused by a virus but
usually they're caused by some sort of
stress whether that means it's a stress
to your immune system it could be a
stress like a physical stress like if
you have braces and they're rubbing
along a specific part of your mouth and
inside of your cheek you can get a
canker sore also hot liquids spicy foods
can sometimes cause canker sores really
a physical stress cold sores come from a
virus and unless you have been infected
by that virus you're never gonna get a
cold sore canker sores you can get virus
and no virus Kelly buh
hey Doc what's your intake on dragon's
breath aka liquid nitrogen is it safe to
consume
what dragon's breath it doesn't sound
safe so I wouldn't do it the only thing
that should be going into your lungs is
air and ideally you like it to be clear
air like what we're breathing in New
York City is not ideal so no I think
liquid nitrogen doesn't sound safe to
consume I need more information before I
give you an official doctor's
recommendation Lydia Dimock I often
lucid dream and walk and talk in my
sleep I feel like some nights it could
be causing me to be deprived of sleep
what should I do
oh that's a good one sleepwalking is
actually a problem and sometimes people
realize it luckily because one of their
partners realizes it their family
members realizes it the real solution
here is to get a proper workup from a
doctor hopefully one that specializes in
sleepwalking so that we can figure out
the
perhaps give you a treatment for the
cause whether that means lifestyle
changes or even medications and monitor
your sleep to see if it continues
happening but know that there are
treatments out there Trudy
kool karate what can we do to reduce
muscle soreness after exercises oh man
this is something I struggle with Dom's
delayed onset muscle soreness man I get
this so bad on the second day after like
heavy workout or a new workout things
that I do that I think work quite well
a warm up and cool down are crucial and
it doesn't mean stretching it means like
dynamic warm-ups those are ideal the
second thing is I love massage
even though massage may not improve
circulation as much as we like in
muscles it still feels good it's
relaxing and lowers your cortisol levels
which allows you to recover better and
then the final thing is on the day after
a workout and you feel sore and even the
second day after do a little active
recovery do some of the motions that are
sore but don't do them with heavy
weights so lower by like 80% intensity
of the action and you'll see that your
blood flow will start to improve and
you'll get better recovery that's
something I really enjoy doing entity
303 does stuff what is the best way to
remove sodas at energy drinks from your
diet the best way cold turkey
walk to your fridge take them out spill
them out recycle the bottles and then
say you quit if it's not in your home
and you don't buy it you're not gonna
drink it that's the bottom line
Matty Baker I want it to go and follow
you on Twitter
but your account is suspended what did
you do I didn't do anything I think my
Twitter account is fine I'm gonna look
it up right now no my Twitter account is
fine
maybe you wrote this a long time ago
first of all you need to follow me on
Twitter it's real doctor spelled out
like I post some good articles I give my
opinions on things you really should be
following me there so on Twitter follow
me just say here's an awesome playlist I
put together for you that starts off
with my Hospital vlog literally a full
day in the hospital where I teach
everybody about how to stay happy and
healthy I'll see you on this playlist
let's do it
[Music]